welcome back to New rockers I'm Jessica
Clemens and this is a breakdown of Ekko
episode 2 where we get first hints of
Maya's a magical lineage ooh this
episode had one of the coolest train
Heights I've ever seen in a TV show but
it also left me concerned for the safety
of my poor sweet baby boy biscuits let's
dive in for all the Easter eggs and
details and references you might have
missed but first don't forget to check
out nerd rot. shop where right now you
can find merch inspired by the echo
series including a shirt featuring the
big man himself and a shirt with Echo
spelled down ASL with bloody knuckles
grabbing a piece of merch From Nerd Riot
is a great way to support the channel so
head on over to nerd rot. shop and Shop
all our awesome merch options today
let's get into it we open in Alabama in
1200 ad this is around the same year
that the chiefs of the five irin nations
met in what would become New York State
and agreed to unite after years of
Waring from the concept art they labeled
this as Cahokia the largest city built
north of Mexico before the colonizers
arrived it's a huge huge major city
until about 1350 Ekko visits it in the
comics traveling backwards in time where
she meets her ancestor AO yoa the host
of The Phoenix force during that time
time period in addition to the concept
art looking pretty spoton to what we see
in an interview with Seth Fairchild the
executive director of cultural Services
he mentioned Marvel created The Village
in Stick ball field and made it 100%
authentic to what the chak tribal
members asked for they're traveling by
canoe and Dugout canoes were widely used
pre the arrival of the Europeans the
attention to detail here is just all
remarkable like in the water when
they're canoeing past the shoreline we
see this freaking alligator snapping
turtle native to the Southern United
States dive into the water another shout
out to Ekko and the team really just
standing on their business to be
culturally authentic as possible this is
1200 ad 1200 ad none of us have lived
during that time we're showing you
things we only know from stories and
artifacts and that just really gets me
because it's really important people are
arriving from all over to take part in
watching public sportting event this is
chak toas sbar isoli which is similar to
modern day lacrosse Chaka stickball was
played often in Oklahoma until the early
1900s and helped keep Warriors in shape
for Warfare but also was seen as an
alternative to war between tribes in a
recent interview with the chatan nation
Chief Gary baton makes note of some of
their tribal members being the actors
and actresses in the show this stick
ball game is played by real stick ball
players for 2 days in the heat they
played actual stick ball and used a lot
of that footage amongst the ones you
know obviously choreographed but this is
all impressive incredible and just
completely awesome to me here we find
out that the outcome of this game will
determine which team is banished from
these lands forever two teams play their
hands forearms feet lower legs and lower
part of their faces are painted red and
blue they speak to this man in Cherokee
he has blue paint on so the colors could
signify their tribe they keep score with
sticks painted in the same color and
it's the first to 10 wins there's one
woman on the red team Lok and she's
crushing it she's the MVP the score is 5
to1 in favor of red but then the blue
team decides to send in the ringer this
big beefy dude who seems to have a
history with Lok she trash talks him a
bit but her teammate tells her to not
lose focus it is so easy to fall into a
rut with food but it's also so boring my
problem is that if it's left up to me
I'll eat the same boring stuff every
single day like Zack Huddleston which is
exactly why I'm thrilled when instead of
having to figure it out on my own cook
Unity can do it for me cook Unity is the
first chef to Consumer platform that
delivers freshly prepared pre-selected
meals right to your door weekly cook
Unity is basically a pipeline from your
home to dozens of talented chefs that
cook delicious inventive meals fresh
everyday in Regional micro kitchens not
Warehouse production facilities and the
meals they make are updated weekly so
you can't get bored you can pick from
whopping 350 plus meals each week based
on your dietary needs including
vegetarian pescatarian and keto you know
that's me what kind of Cuisine do you
like or just I don't know give me
chicken I won't forget which could be
the eser Cho Teriyaki roasted salmon or
if you're more in the mood for beef you
could have a Stacy bearing grilled Asian
hanger steak with charred broccolini
variety is the spice of life and with
cook Unity you can live a spicy life
cook unity's roster of All-Star chefs
include Food Network alums James Beard
award winners and acclaimed restaurant
turs balancing flavor and nutrition in
the Creations there is seemingly endless
variety of meals to choose from the
subscription is super flexible you can
pause skip weeks or cancel at any time
and it's super easy to do go to cook
unity.com enrock stars50 or click the
link in the description and use my code
n rockstars 50 to get 50% off your first
order of cook Unity meals to try them
out for yourself when play starts up
again he intercepts the ball right in
front of her face and she is pissed the
score is now tied 9 to9 the next Point
wins the teams get into a scrum in the
midst of the chaos the woman starts
having flashes of her ancestors and she
sees the glowing spiral on her Palms
similar to what Maya sees later on in
this episode The Woman leaps over
everyone and Scores And The Crowd Goes
Wild in present day Maya wakes up to the
light in her room flashing to indicate
that someone is at the door she has two
text on her phone from her cousin
biscuits reading I'm here and brought
some stuff there's a notepad next to her
phone with a list it says four rolls of
duct tape 15 glow sticks this is a party
and I want to be invited small lanterns
drill Sledgehammer carabiners climbing
rope harness just harness sealant Vienna
sausages is this a child or a kidnapper
biscuits brought Maya some Essentials in
a postal carrier box which we later find
out is Grandma cholas along with her
truck he's driving Maya ominously ask
him if he ever takes the truck
off-roading and he gives an enthetic
never because grandma would kill him and
he's not good with the steering wheel on
the wrong side it's on the wrong side
because she's a US postal worker and she
uses the truck on her postal route in
the Box he's got Doritos fions
strawberry poptarts pasteurized
processed cheddar cheese and that's a
good cousin right there he's got all the
Staples and is really a sweet dude who
we see later is willing to do some crazy
stuff for his cousin Maya hands him a
supply list of things she needs and he
says it's not illegal is it and she just
hands him a lot of cash and doesn't
answer Biscuit Goes to scully's pawn
shop to get me or her list of stuff and
I called the number on the sign in there
and sadly it was not in service so you
don't need to do it I called like most
of the numbers in this series and none
of them are in service I was hoping for
a personalized screening from Kingpin
himself cuz that's exactly what I dream
of and what I want Scully store sells
Native American Goods among other things
and we get this hilarious scene with
these two clueless wasps who get talked
into buying a bunch of stuff from Scully
who's obviously used to dealing with
these type of people
the the D by the dam Thing by the dam
thing oh All My Relations yeah and in
case you can't tell what he's saying
he's chanting by the damn thing over and
over again but they clearly hear what
they want to hear the was want some
Navajo rugs that are a little more
Southwest D but biscuits talks them out
of anthropology and they leave Scully
decked in The Fringe vest and bolo ties
biscuits says this oh you guys can drive
over to anthropology and get your Navajo
rug but that's all stuff from Mador we
saw Mador and Falcon and the Winter
Soldier with Baron Zemo Sam Wilson and
Bucky went to Mador to meet the Power
broker AKA Sharon Carter it's full of
the world's shadiest criminals and this
is also a playoff the you know made in
China kind of Trope on the way out the
white woman says you Ki which is chocked
up for thank you and she was probably so
proud of herself for that and then
biscuit says this I don't know why you
got to be all somehow I just helped you
with that sale with the noos noos which
is chocked out for white people Maya's
grandma is helping a plan for some type
of festival and the diagram they look at
has a similar layout to the one from the
opening scene with the chak to stickball
game someone in the group accidentally
spills the beans that Maya's back in
town and they spotted her talking to
Henry at the roller rink and you just
know that Grandma Trolla isn't mad she's
just disappointed biscus brings
everything he got from skullies over to
Maya's house and she peer pressures him
into skipping dinner with Chola to take
a ride with her instead and I'm afraid
for biscuits at this point going forward
he's just easily peer pressured just
like me grandma Chola goes to the roller
ring to talk to Henry about Maya being
back in town and I love that song
everyone is skating to it's the 1998 All
My Life by Casey and
Jojo I was listening to it because I
love this song so much it's just such a
good roller skating song they're always
playing those 90 ballads at roller rings
CH is worried that Maya will cause
trouble while she's in town and her
fears are totally founded because
immediately we found out that Maya has
been planning this whole time with a
list of supplies and it's a dangerous
ass train Heist I don't even know if
it's a heist more than is a horrible
terrorist attack Maya ropes biscuits
into helping her with this too and he
brings along Billy Jack and I love him
and was so concerned for his safety for
everything that follows but spoiler
alert Billy Jack is totally fine since I
i' want to know that before going into
this so you're welcome Maya goes all
Mission Impossible and jumps onto a
moving train and I love that this isn't
graceful or easy like she almost falls
off and it's a lot of hard work to get
herself back up her whole Life's a
struggle but that's when she goes hard
it's not the usual action movie type
scene it's brutal and she's getting beat
up doing all this stuff it kind of
reminds me of the awesome Daredevil
season one hallway fight scene where you
saw every bit of effort that fight took
Matt to accomplish and he was bloody and
battered and breathing hard the entire
time this scene switches from this loud
train to Maya's POV silent calm still
even as the crazy chaos is Raging around
her she jumps over the head of the armed
guard without him noticing and then
gives a yeah I just did that smile back
that's just awesome once she's
underneath the train she drills up into
the container d9x and puts a small
camera she had biscuits get her up in
there to look around biscuits is
frantically trying to keep up with Maya
and the train and Grandma chol's truck
and Chola Calls him right as this is
happening Grandma's always know when
you're up to no good even her look on
his phone looks disappointing I'm also
starting to get a bad feeling that
biscuits is going to die before this
series is even over like he's always
just too sweet and Maya keeps putting
him In Harm's Way and it's all just
doesn't bode well with me Maya enters
the container d9x and opens a box but we
don't get to see what's inside of it
which is very pul fiction she puts
something in the box then seals it up
with sealant spray after she's done what
she's come there to do she's back on top
of the train and miscalculates on a jump
crushing her prosthetic leg in a
horrible way I hate this scene I hate it
I don't ever want to see it again in a
moment of pure panic when she's trying
to free her leg Maya sees a vision of
low walk the dick ball playing woman
from the beginning of the episode then
she sees the woman from episode one who
became the first Chaka Maya's hand glows
with the same swirling circles as loax
did and she's able to pry the train cars
apart to free her leg then we get this
awesome moment that we saw in the
trailer where Maya jumps from the moving
train to the truck biscuits is driving
and again this hits hard biscuits checks
to make sure Billy Jack the dog is okay
and again that's exactly the first thing
I would have done too we see the New
York skyline but specifically the view
from the Freedom Tower in Manhattan
which is away from a Avengers Tower
that's Uptown so we're not seeing
Avengers Tower yet in this shot it turns
out that Maya rigged the box with
explosives so that when it reaches the
end of the line and the workers open it
it just blows up in their faces it's
hard to tell what's in the crate before
it explodes but it kind of looks like
weapons it's also hard to tell what the
bomb is made of but it does look like a
homemade bomb and none of the
ingredients look like they were on the
list Maya gave to biscuit so maybe he's
not an accomplice to the bombing itself
the items she had biscuit acquir were
just a break into the train I'm not a
lawyer but hopefully that holds up in
court because I love biscuits don't want
him in trouble anyways it blows the hell
out of that warehouse and this is some
real anti-hero right here and I
mean M could have just taken out any
innocent person who happened to be
walking by not to mention the fact that
probably not all those dudes there were
like bad and deserve this it's giving
it's giving us agent Henry has three
phones and all of them ring at once he's
clearly being told about the train car
in the warehouse but he hasn't yet put
two and two together to know that may
had anything to do with this but then he
realizes which container BW and he text
her we need to talk now and you know
that if there's periods at the end of
sentences in a text that person means
business they're mad Maya goes to Scully
to get her prosthetic leg fixed up and I
love how everyone in her life just knows
American Sign Language and it isn't
presented as like a big deal Scully
immediately knows Maya's up to some crap
when he looks at her damaged leg and she
shows him the new leg she wants I was
kind of thinking of that shotgun leg
that Rose McGowan has imp planted Terror
during this scene but Ma's probably
asking for something a little more
practical then we get this cool Montage
of Scully building the leg very
reminiscent of Tony Stark building his
suit out of the box of scraps box of
scraps and just like Tony's first suit
this leg is temporary the real one will
take some time for him to make Maya
takes Henry the hit me I hit back and
damn girl don't put that stuff in a text
that's how they nail you Henry takes
back they'll know this was you you can't
take on fist's Army alone and she
responds they can't do much with their
Armory melted m is a statue of the woman
from her vision the first chaa and
Scully tells her that her grandmother
can trace her Roots back to the very
first Chaka and the ancestors would look
out for the family in times of need so I
guess that explains the glowy hand thing
speaking of grand Maola the look that
biscuits gives her when he knows he's
busted for messing up her truck is
amazing he just drives by I just love
this scene it's it's very funny biscuits
is going to be one of our favorite
characters biscuits takes the truck to
Snake Creek Salvage and gets on the CB
to try and sell his PlayStation 4 for
money to get it fixed up he asked for
125 her best offer and right now use
PlayStation 4 goes for around 175 on
GameStop Bonnie hears biscuits on the CB
as he slips and says that Maya's in town
again not to curse biscuits but this
dude is definitely going to die before
this series is over he's just too sweet
and naive Henry Compares Maya to Fisk
saying she sounds like him and we know
from the trailer that Fisk himself will
make this comparison at some point Henry
also says Maya needs to lay low and that
people close to her always get hurt and
oh yeah someone's going to die if not
biscuits maybe Bonnie or Grandma Chola
and I'm going to be crushed no matter
what cuz none of these people deserve to
die they're all innocent Bonnie texts
Maya are you here in town why wouldn't
you tell me this is just as Maya is
looking at the swing set where they
played when they were little she flashes
back to their sleepover in the tent the
night her mom died and these memories
have baggage because in the present day
she shoots up the swing set the gunshots
are intercut with more scenes of Maya's
ancestors the woman in the cave looking
back at her and then a black and white
shot of a woman we haven't seen before
she's holding a shotgun and has braids
and a cowboy hat and this is the image
we go out on and that's it for my
breakdown on episode 2 of Ekko I'll be
back tomorrow for my breakdown episode 3
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thank you Gina for
writing this episode it takes a village
to make these videos and Gina wrote this
one because she's amazing spectacular
and the love of my life thanks for
watching I'll see you
[Music]
tomorrow